hey this is pressure Locker this classic
problem is making the rounds because it
is easy to state but evidently it's
extremely hard for adults to solve can
you figure it out
the problem is to make three squares of
equal size by moving three of the sticks
the problem is like it sounds there are
no other tricks you are not allowed to
break any of the six the three resulting
squares must be of equal size and each
stick in the resulting shape must be
part of the square give this problem a
try and when you're ready keep watching
the video for the solution the only
difficult part is selecting which sticks
to move here is one possible solution on
our first move will move this stick this
will be our second move and this will be
our third move and what we have is a
shape that has three squares of equal
size now due to the symmetry of the
problem you could have also found this
by moving three other sticks you may
have also come up with the same shape
upside down but this is the basic
solution did you figure it out thanks
for watching this video please subscribe
to my channel I make videos on math and
game theory you can catch one on my blog
mind your decisions which you can follow
on Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
catch me on social media at pressure
Locker and if you liked this video
please check out my books there links in
the video description